BUT THEY HAVE TO COME IN
LEGALLY.
VERY SIMPLE.
>> Harris: LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
I WANT TO GET BACK A MOMENT AND
REVISIT THE COVID-19.
YOU RAN ON -- VERY STRONGLY ON
THE BORDER.
THAT WAS A SINGLE ISSUE FOR YOU.
THE PANDEMIC HADN’T HAPPENED.
BIDEN RAN STRONGLY ON COVID-19.
YET I’M LEARNING FROM CHAD WOLF
YOUR FORMER ACTING DHS
SECRETARY AND DEMOCRATS AS WELL
THAT PEOPLE ARE CROSSING THE
BORDER AND SOMETIMES WE CAN
TEST THEM AND SOMETIMES WE
CAN’T.
AS A FORMER PRESIDENT YOU KNOW
A LOT OF DETAILS WE DON’T HAVE
ACCESS RIGHT NOW TO BECAUSE WE
HAVEN’T HAD OUR FIRST SOLO NEWS
CONFERENCE WITH BIDEN.
I WILL ASK YOU A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FROM A PRESIDENT’S
PERSPECTIVE.
TITLE 42, WHAT WOULD IT DO TO
STEM THE TIDE IN TERMS OF
COVID-19 RIGHT NOW?
IS IT BEING APPLIED IN YOUR
ESTIMATION?
YOU CREATED THAT.
>> THEY ARE APPLYING NOTHING.
THEY AREN’T DOING TITLE 42 OR
ANY TITLE.
PEOPLE ARE JUST POURING INTO
OUR COUNTRY AND THEY WILL
DESTROY OUR COUNTRY.
THEY WILL DESTROY OUR COUNTRY.
YOU CAN’T TAKE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE.
THEY’LL HAVE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
BEFORE THIS MESS IS OVER.
THEY’VE GOT SOME KIND OF
POLITICAL THEORY, I GUESS, THAT
IT’S A GOOD THING.
I THINK IT’S A VERY BAD THING
FOR OUR COUNTRY.
AGAIN, WE WANT PEOPLE TO COME
IN BUT THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
HELP OUR COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE TO COME IN THROUGH
MERIT AND COME IN LEGALLY.
RIGHT NOW YOU DON’T HAVE
ANYTHING PROTECTING OUR COUNTRY.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE JUST FLOWING
THROUGH, COMING THROUGH.
THE NUMBERS ARE SO VAST NOBODY
HAS EVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE IT.
IF THEY SAID 20 YEARS I BET
IT’S MAYBE FOREVER.
MAYBE IT’S FROM THE BEGINNING
OF THIS WHOLE MESS.
IT IS MUCH MORE THAN 20 YEARS.
THEY SAID THE WORST IN 20 YEARS.
THEY WILL DESTROY OUR COUNTRY.
IN OTHER WAYS TOO IF YOU LOOK
AT WHAT’S GOING ON.
YOU’LL HAVE PACK THE COURT, BIG
TAX INCREASES, THEY WILL TAKE
YOUR GUNS AWAY.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THEY’RE
DOING WITH -- TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT’S COMING UP.
I PREDICTED IT ALL.
I MUST SAY I NEVER THOUGHT THAT
BIDEN -- IT’S NOT BIDEN, IT’S
OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE PUTTING
STUFF IN FRONT OF HIM BUT I
NEVER THOUGHT THAT BIDEN IN A
MILLION YEARS WOULD BE WORSE.
NOBODY DID, WOULD BE FAR WORSE
THAN BERNIE SANDERS.
THIS IS BERNIE SANDERS ON
STEROIDS.
THIS IS WHAT HE IS DOING WITH
ALL -- YOU HAVEN’T SEEN
ANYTHING YET.
SO THE SECOND AMENDMENT IS
GOING TO BE OBLITERATED, THERE
IS NO STOPPING THEM.
OUR LEADERSHIP, MITCH ISN’T
STRONG ENOUGH TO STOP PEOPLE.
NEVER WAS.
IT’S LIKE ONE OF THE BIG
SECRETS.
BUT HE HAD THE MAJORITY.
BUT NOW THAT HE IS NOT IN THE
MAJORITY, HE IS NOT DOING HIS
THING.
HE IS NOT DOING WHAT HE SHOULD
BE DOING.
THERE ARE WAYS TO STOP SOME OF
THIS STUFF THAT’S HAPPENING BUT
YOU WILL SEE PACKING THE COURTS.
YOU WILL SEE THE BIGGEST TAX
INCREASE IN HISTORY.
YOU WILL SEE THE SECOND
AMENDMENT JUST ABSOLUTELY
OBLITERATED.
YOU WILL SEE MANY OTHER THINGS.
THE GREEN NEW DEAL WILL BE PUT
INTO EFFECT.
PEOPLE USED TO LAUGH AT IT WHEN
IT WAS PROPOSED THREE YEARS AGO
BY PEOPLE THAT KNEW NOTHING
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT AND
THEY’LL RAISE TAXES TO A LEVEL
AND SPEND A LOT OF THE MONEY
FOOLISHLY ON GREEN NEW DEAL
STUFF THAT DOESN’T WORK.
>> Harris: I WANT TO ASK MY
TEAM TO PUT UP A COUPLE OF
NUMBERS.
WE’RE SHOWING SOME INFORMATION
FOR OUR VIEWERS, MR. PRESIDENT,
AS YOU ARE TALKING AND MATCHING
UP A LITTLE BIT.
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
SURGE AT THE BORDER.
LET’S GO BACK TO THE SOUTHWEST
BORDER.
ADULTS UP 188%.
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS, I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE CHILDREN BECAUSE
THAT’S THE MARK AGAINST OUR
SOUL AND YOUR ADMINISTRATION
TOOK CRITICISM BECAUSE WE WERE
TAKING IN UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
AND THEY WERE GETTING SEPARATED
FROM THE ADULTS AT THE BORDER
AND YOU SEE THAT EVERYBODY ON
THE SCREEN, 92% INCREASE OF
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS NOW IN
2021 VERSUS 2020.
WE’RE ONLY THREE MONTHS IN.
AS WE LOOK AT THE SCREEN I WANT
TO MATCH THAT NOW.
MR. PRESIDENT, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THESE NUMBERS, AND YOU LOOK AT
WHAT WIPED AWAY ON THE FIRST
DAY OF PRESIDENT BIDEN’S
ADMINISTRATION AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER, WHAT EXACTLY WERE YOU
DOING THAT WAS WORKING BETTER
THAN WHAT WE SEE NOW?
I UNDERSTAND THAT PEOPLE WERE
FLOWING OVER NOW BUT THERE WERE
SOME THINGS THAT YOU DID, YOU
HAD AGREEMENTS WITH HONDURAS,
ECUADOR, GUATEMALA, MEXICO.
I WANT THE AUDIENCE TO
UNDERSTAND SOME OF WHAT WAS
WIPED AWAY MORE THAN JUST WELL
IT HAD MY NAME ON IT.
THOSE NUMBERS THAT WE’RE
LOOKING AT NOW ARE A MARK
AGAINST US.
THESE CHILDREN, THEIR LIVES ARE
FOREVER DIFFERENT IF THEY MAKE
IT.
>> THE ONLY PROBLEM WITH GIVING
YOU THIS ANSWER, YOU DON’T HAVE
ENOUGH TIME.
YOU NEED ABOUT TWO HOURS TO
EXPLAIN WHAT WE’VE DONE.
WHAT WE DID IS INCREDIBLE.
BUT IN A NUTSHELL I DO WANT TO
START OFF BY SAYING THEY BUILT
THE CAGES.
THEY BUILT CAGES FOR CHILDREN.
WE DIDN’T BUILD THEM, THEY
BUILT THEM.
FAMOUS PICTURE APPEARED ABOUT
THE CAGES BUILT AND FORTUNATELY
SOMEBODY REMEMBERED AND
FORTUNATELY WE HAVE GUYS LIKE
MORGAN AND TOM HOMAN, SUCH
PROFESSIONALS.
I WATCH THEM ON YOUR SHOW.
THEY REALLY KNOW THEIR BUSINESS.
THEY ARE NOT INVOLVED WITH THIS.
THEY HAVE PEOPLE THAT HAVE NO
IDEA.
THEY BUILT CAGES IN 2014 BUT
THAT WAS DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
AND THEY BLAMED THEM ON US.
WE DIDN’T BUILD THE CAGES.
THEY DID.
VERY SAD WHEN THEY HAD A
PICTURE IN THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
OF CHILDREN IN CAGES AND IT
TURNED OUT IT WAS THEM.
THE NEWSPAPER DIDN’T WANT TO DO
RESTRAK SHUNS EVEN THOUGH NOW
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT’S THE FACT.
BUT AS FAR AS OTHER COUNTRIES
ARE CONCERNED.
SO WE HAD GUATEMALA, HONDURAS,
EL SALVADOR AND OTHERS.
WE WERE PAYING THOSE THREE
COUNTRIES APPROXIMATELY $500
MILLION A YEAR.
WHO KNOWS WHAT THEY WERE DOING
WITH THE MONEY.
YOU CAN IMAGINE.
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO USE THAT
MONEY FOR ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND KEEP PEOPLE THERE.
IT SOUNDS GOOD BUT IT WASN’T
BEING USED FOR THAT.
PEOPLE WERE FLOWING IN.
THEY WOULDN’T TAKE MS-13 GANG
MEMBERS BACK.
THEY WOULDN’T TAKE ANYBODY BACK
FOR OBAMA.
THEY WOULDN’T DO IT.
THEY SAID NOPE, DON’T EVER LAND
YOUR PLANE HERE OR BRING YOUR
BUSES HERE, DON’T EVER SEND A
BOAT, NOTHING.
WE WON’T TAKE THEM BACK.
TURN AROUND.
THEY WERE TURNING OUR PEOPLE
AROUND TREATING US LIKE
AMATEURS, WHICH IS WHAT THEY
WERE.
AND SO I SAID WELL, THEY WERE
DOING THAT AT THE BEGINNING OF
MINE, TOO.
HOW MUCH MONEY DO WE PAY THESE
COUNTRIES?
$500 MILLION.
I SAID STOP PAYMENT.
AS SOON AS I STOPPED PAYMENT
ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY SAID WE
WOULD WELCOME OUR MS-13 GANG
MEMBERS BACK INTO OUR COUNTRY.
WE WOULD WELCOME.
I GOT ALONG VERY WELL WITH
THOSE THREE COUNTRIES AND
REALLY WELL WITH MEXICO.
THE PRESIDENT OF MEXICO IS A
FRIEND OF MINE, A GREAT GUY.
>> Harris: I KNOW I’LL HAVE TO
LET YOU GO SOON.
I WANT TO GET THIS IN THERE.
IS THAT PART OF WHAT’S GONE?
IS BIDEN MAINTAINING THESE
RELATIONSHIPS?
WE CAN’T DO THIS WITHOUT THE
COUNTRIES SOUTH OF THE BORDER.
WE HAD VIDEO AND WE CAN GO BACK
TO TIJUANA, MEXICO, THERE WERE
TENT CITIES THAT HAVE SET UP ON
THE BORDER WAITING TO GET BACK
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
WAITING.
>> ALL THOSE PEOPLE WILL COME
FLOODING IN.
I KEPT THEM IN MEXICO.
BY KEEPING THEM IN MEXICO
MEXICO BECOMES MUCH TOUGHER AT
THEIR NORTHERN BORDER AND THEY
DON’T WANT ANYMORE.
I SAID TO MEXICO IF YOU ARE
GOING TO DO ANY OF THIS STUFF
THAT’S BAD FOR US I’LL PUT
TARIFFS ON ALL THE CARS YOU
MAKE FOR THE UNITED STATES
BECAUSE BEFORE MY
ADMINISTRATION THEY SELL 32% OF
OUR AUTO MAKING BUSINESS.
THE UNIONS DON’T REALIZE THAT.
UNION MEMBERS REALIZE IT BUT
THE HEADS OF THE UNIONS THAT
ALL SUPPORT DEMOCRATS NO MATTER
WHO THEY ARE DON’T REALIZE IT.
THEY TOOK 32% OF OUR AUTOMOBILE
BUSINESS.
ALL THOSE CARS YOU MAKE WILL BE
TEAR ARIFFED.
MEXICO WAS GREAT.
>> Harris: THEY AREN’T DOING
THAT ANYMORE.
>> THEY HAVE A FIELD DAY.
THEY HAVE PEOPLE RANK AMATEURS,
THEY HAVE PEOPLE THAT TALK
ABOUT IDEOLOGY BUT IT IS NOT
EVEN GOOD IDEOLOGY.
WHY WOULD IT WORK?
WHY ARE WE SUPPOSED TO TAKE
CARE OF THE WORLD?
IN MANY CASES THE WORLD’S
CRIMINALS.
THEY’RE COMING OVER NOT FROM
THE THREE COUNTRIES PLUS MEXICO.
THEY’RE COMING FROM YEMEN, FROM
THE MIDDLE EAST.
WHO THE HELL KNOWS WHAT WE’RE
TAKING IN?
THESE PEOPLE ARE DESTROYING OUR
COUNTRY.
I SAID IT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
THAT’S WHY I GOT 75 MILLION
VOTES.
PROBABLY MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
AND IT IS A DISGRACE WHAT HAS
BEEN ALLOWED TO HAPPEN TO OUR
COUNTRY AND THEY ARE
PERSECUTING PEOPLE.
THEY ARE STOPPING THEM FROM
TALKING.
THEY ARE STOPPING FREE SPEECH
AND THEY ARE PERSECUTING GREAT
AMERICANS.
>> Harris: LET’S GET INTO THAT.
LET’S GET INTO THE FACT THAT AS
MEDIA WE CANNOT GET INTO THIS
BORDER SITUATION.
THAT THERE IS A LID ON US WITH
REGARD TO THOSE FACILITIES.
DID YOUR ADMINISTRATION EVER
CONSIDER SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IS DOING, CLOSING DOWN A BORDER?
I STILL DON’T UNDERSTAND, BY
THE WAY, MR. PRESIDENT HOW IT
WOULD WORK IF IT’S SO POROUS
THE WAY IT IS.
>> THAT’S WHY YOU NEEDED THE
WALL.
I BUILT ALMOST 500 MILES OF
IT IS A MUCH EASIER SITUATION
NOW.
WHEN I TOOK OVER IT WAS A
DISASTER.
I BUILT 500 MILES OF WALL AND
NOW YOU HAVE VAST SECTIONS.
YOU SEE SOME OPENING BUT THE
OPENINGS GET CLOSED.
YOU HAVE TO CLOSE THEM.
THOSE CONTRACTS HAVE BEEN GIVEN
A LONG TIME AGO.
AGAIN, THAT WAS TO GET PEOPLE
THROUGH BUT THESE ARE SMALL
OPENINGS.
BUT THAT HAS TO GET CLOSED.
BUT THE WALL HAS MADE IT SO
MUCH EASIER FOR THESE PEOPLE.
FRANKLY, I MEAN, I EVEN HEAR
THEY WANT TO TEAR DOWN THE WALL
IF YOU CAN BELIEVE IT.
TEAR DOWN THE WALL, YOU KNOW?